WINS CAME OVER THE TOP TEAMSOF
GOES UP, THE OUTSTANDING FROM E
THE FASTBACK OUT, WANTING
TO KNOCK DOWN IN FRONTAND FOR S
HE PUTS HIS STICK UP IN FRONT
OF HIS GOA A
PRODUCTION PLAYER FOR SOME OF
COULDN'T HANDLE THAT PASS, HAD
A LOT OF HEAT ON IT.,
AND McEWEN HAD A H
CONNOR BROWN WILL GET THE PUCK
OUT,. DE.
NOT A GOALON GOAL, HE SCORES.
MARK AND JONES IF HE GETS
CHABOT ACROSS,'S AH THE CORNER,T
DOWN THERE, BUT, IT DEFLECTS TO
KONECNY, GOOD WORK, THERE,
ON THE ONSIDE OF THE N
PUSHED OUT,, TO GET ON THE RIGH,
WASHINGTON,
PHILADELPHIA.  DENIED, BACK IN,
ON THIS SHOT.  EYES, TO
THE DEFLECTION. , AND RIGHT THE.
SLIDING THAT PUCK
CHANGE THE LINE, INTO  OUT IN TT
SANHEIM ENDS IT